[Music]
i have to ask you about this but uh your
husband i think this offer came from
your husband yeah you'll tell me if it's
correct but when i was going through my
uh kooky travails about two and a half
years ago
uh and i didn't know what i was going to
do for a living next
very publicly your husband who created
the show
kurt sutter put out this very public
offer for he said conan o'brien come be
a cast member on sons of anarchy
which at the time i didn't have a job i
didn't know what i was going to do and
it first of all it it blew me away b i
thought
i'm the worst person where would i fit
i'm sons of anarchy there's no
what guy would i be season three we went
to ireland you could have been
you're irish
yeah but you could have been oh and we
had but wait a minute but you still need
bad asses right you could have been a
badass irish biker
really
look if i come back we're going to get
you
oh
i'll get johnny bicyclist
a bicycle
[Applause]
i love the eye first of all i absolutely
love the idea of me playing a badass i
think people would get a huge kick out
of it if i had a crazy mustache that
went down here and then crossed over you
could have
[Applause]
i could have that hair and i could be in
ireland i got the cornrows i tell you
you could you could be a goofy biker
you could be a goofy biker i can't do
goofy
getting angry at this crowd
um well i was very honored to get the
offer and i stand at the ready and i
would single-handedly ruin that show
that's beautiful i don't think so he'd
write you a really interesting you could
like kill i'm sure oh no no i would are
you kidding i'd use all the pumpkin
stuff on something oh my god you know
well be careful what you wish for he'll
be all right the offers will be coming
in i'll be doing it he's a big fan oh
really i'll be doing it i'll be showing
up at sons of anarchy um well we have a
clip here from the show and i believe
this is a scene you're doing with mr
jimmy smith yes exactly right smith
who's on the show and um
do we need any setup for this i'm not
sure it lays out pretty nicely i think
you were in the hospital i believe oh
that's correct rachel yes i believe oh i
think i did you're in the hospital and
you did something very bad and you're
confessing that to jimmy smith all right
okay i love that i'm setting up your
colleagues you set it up great
and you're katie seagal and you're on
sons of anarchy
let's take a look okay
i was stoned driving those kids
i thought i'd be okay
i drive high all the time
and i
i didn't want to miss my chance to be
with them i hear you it's okay baby
it's okay no it's not
clay lied for me
told jack someone ran me off the road
i let him believe it
it's an excellent show
i'm so happy for you thank you
congratulations